luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and
welcome back to the lehigh fans show
of course it's um powered by icon plus
capital they're a vc firm so go check
them out rose jose how you doing good to have
you look you need to teach me how to do that
i need to do one of those introductions no that
was beautiful i need to learn how to do those
fancy transitions and i like stream yard i do
have an account but i just don't know how to do
that you need to teach me oh sure yeah no i made
it myself so i could take these two um but before
we jump in um i just want to let everybody know
that this is sponsored by blockfy so blockfy are
a really cool place to basically earn i think
it's up to eight point six percent interest
on your stable coins that's insane because
right now the world is just terrible
um everywhere is the negative interest rates or
flat interest rates so yeah i definitely go check
them out um but for those i don't know jose is
um my guest today he's an absolute online genius
um he's a business online coaching genius master
of all trades so i just want to please his brains
and basically um understand how to grow a business
in 2021 so jose where are you based right now
i'm in dominican republic the
land where it's always summer
gosh i'm so jealous i was in dominican republic
actually just before um just before covid kicked
off um in january 2009 twitter 2020 right
that's just that's what happened right yep
know each other back then we didn't we didn't
but i was doing bachata and i really got down
with the whole dominican republic vibe can
you do bachata i don't like bachata it's weird
because most dominicans love bachata music but i
just don't like it i'm more of a rock guy so um
you know there's a big difference between bachata
and rock so i'm not the right person to ask about
that type of music no fair enough but i love i
love dominican republic um i was in punta cana
um it's a great place but correct me if i'm wrong
before you were online you before you were you
know building your business online and everything
you couldn't speak english is that right
it was hard to speak english okay um i was born
in a family um my dad is an immigrant he is from
belize and people in belize they speak a weird
english when i listen to my dad talking with
my grandparents i don't understand because it has
like weird accent but regardless of that he never
spoke to me or my brother in english but but um
he he had a job here in dominican republic and um
in a school in a very good bilingual school so i
got a scholarship because he was a teacher there
and i learned like the basics of english but after
that i never used english i i only read it i only
watch a couple of movies in english so reading and
listening english is not the same as speaking it
it's not the same thing so i remember my first
couple of live sessions where i was talking in
english and i was like stumbling upon my words
i couldn't find a way to convey my ideas in a
way that was persuasive or entertaining or just
you know without long pauses or or weird sounds
with my boys with the with the you know the you
knows the arms the um and the long long pauses so
since then that was 2018 when i started
like posting stuff in english and
trying to do my best speaking this language
i've come a long way what do you what you're
listening right now it's not what you listen
what you would have listened three years ago man
it's so embarrassing but the thing is that oh
no matter where you start you'll suck at first
and that's normal the difference between people
who succeed online or in life are those who don't
mind embarrassing themselves a little
bit because at the end of the day
um if you don't risk embarrassment like dude what
are you doing with your life are you are you going
to hide yourself under your under your bed weeping
that it's too hard to get started or people will
laugh at you of course people will laugh at you
of course people will make fun of you when you're
when you're starting out because you're doing
it wrongly and that's okay because you're a big
you're a starter so um it's not that i did
not know english is that i did not use english
for 30 years okay i'm 33 by the way i learned
english like when i was like eight nine years old
and stopped learning it when i was like 12 so i
spent four years learning english when i was a kid
after that it's just reading and watching movies
but no speaking until i was like 30 years old so
it was a long time between actually using
the skill learning the skill and using it
and thankfully i did thankfully i
did because look when i started out
my online business my online journey not
business it was not a business back then
what i did was um i started tweeting i started
using twitter to connect with other people and
try to make money but i sucked at it like badly
man i made zero dollars for for a long time for
months um and what i did was i wrote everything
in spanish okay and then i used google translate
to get the english right because no really i did
not write good english but i'm a good writer in
spanish okay so i wrote everything in spanish
and then translated with google translate and
then tweeted the stuff and people start loving
the tweets and retweeting the tweets but they
didn't know it was a translation from spanish
to english it was a very dumb and stupid and
beautiful process no no wait wait wait let me let
me use a little bit of hyperbole to make this more
it's your podcast you go for it jose gone
so yeah it was stupid but it worked and
the reason i tell you about this stupidity of
mine is because when people start a business
when people are thinking about starting a business
or they have a business idea for the online world
or outside of it like in real life they might
feel that their idea is stupid or that's dumb
or that it might not work but let me tell you i'm
the guy who used to translate his exposed from
spanish to english using google translate and
created a multi-six figure business doing that
so if i can do that translate stuff from spanish
to english with a very painful process of thinking
in spanish then translating it then trying to
figure out the best way to say it because the
translation was not perfect and built a six-figure
business with that using the dumpster fire called
the dumpster fire social media called twitter
what makes you think that your next business
idea regardless of how stupid or dumb you feel it
is can't succeed let me give you another example
there's a funny page i love it's called potato
parcel what they do is they you know take the
potato they just take the potato and they engrave
your face on the potato and the potato skin that's
all they do and they sell the freaking potato
for 20 30 think about this a potato one one
piece of potato twenty to thirty dollars and
they right now are a million dollar business
selling engraved potatoes with yours is it good
though is it good is it like an actual business
it's a million dollar business of course
the potato spoils because it's a real potato
but it's it's like a gag you know it's like a
like a joke you send the potato to someone with
like what the hell is this potato doing with my
face on it so but does it look like the person
yes they really they really they it's not engraved
they actually print your face on the potato okay
so um they built a business with a dumb
idea and they and they scaled it to a
million dollar business so whatever the hell
you're thinking about um right now for you
to start a business think about the potato
parcel uh brand or think about me the guy who
who used to translate his stuff from english to
spanish using google translate to get the english
the english right and build a six-figure multi-six
figure business doing that think about that
what makes you think you can't so i always smile
telling the story because a lot of people approach
me telling me jose how do i start a business how
do i scale how what should i post what should i
do how do i get clients how do i get started
how do i reach out to people and my answer to
them is always um the following right now you're
focusing on problems that you don't have what
you need to do is ask yourself the question that
will solve an immediate problem and the immediate
problem that you have right now is when well
the question that solves the immediate problem
that you have right now is when do i need to get
started and the answer to that question is always
yesterday okay not now yesterday the answer to
that question is yesterday so once you get started
you'll do it badly and give yourself permission
to do it badly like you're new at something even
michael jordan when he started shooting you know
the ball and and trying to dunk he sucked at it
and now he's michael jordan or think about um uh
tiger woods when he started with his golfing and
stuff like that i he he was not good at it and
now he's like the best in history so when you're
starting out give yourself permission to do it
badly now when i say give yourself permission
to do it badly it's not to do it as bad as you can
is that do it knowing it will it won't be perfect
okay because you're a beginner you're starting
out and what happens next what happens next once
you get started which you should do right now
okay or after you stop listening to our podcast
right um then you start you will start
getting more questions inside your head
and your mission is to this is to
figure out which of those questions
um we'll reserve when you answer one of those
questions will result in an immediate return on
your investment you'll solve the problems as they
start appearing in front of your face in front of
your face you don't solve problems that you still
don't have that's when you're starting out okay
once you have two or three five years in business
it's better to have a longer-term vision for your
business but when you're starting out is
day-to-day what problem do i have today
that i can solve today and that i can see an
immediate return on the investment of the time
and effort i'm going to invest in trying to solve
that problem that will bring me i don't know the
best results at the moment when you're starting
out this is the best approach solve the problems
as they start appearing i'm just going to jump
in jose wait jose i just going to jump in a sec
so several things going on here and i'm reading
the comments as well so i want to make sure that
we add as much value as possible so if you
guys do have any comments um then definitely
just put them in because i'm reading them as we
chat um but okay so really important you said
about being embarrassed i think that is so key
um especially just from a personal standpoint
i just i just push things out like even
even if i i look stupid or i seem silly
um i also think there's there's something kind
of charming um about making a fool of yourself um
just not because of course you don't want to say
anything stupid and you don't be incorrect or
or whatever it is stupid i like how do you say
it stupid yeah yeah but i just love the english
accent like stupid yeah same same as tuesday
and yeah tuesday yeah i love the memes also
yeah it's funny um but you know a lot of the time
people do trial and error and they're not sure
what the best business is okay i have a friend
i was talking about this with her the other day
she wants to grow online and and you know build
a business but she doesn't know what her niche
is and i think a niche is often quite important
so what if people are trying to figure out what
business should i do you know i'm good at many
different things or i'm rubbish at many different
things how can they really narrow it down whether
it be fitness um motivation you know these are
just some of the key things which people do
online at the moment so how do they actually
focus and pick something well that's a great
question and i will not answer it i'll answer
a different question okay at least you're honest
about it that's fine yeah let's let's let's let's
make this a little bit spicier look um i am
not the type of person that will say someone
hey choose a niche and then start your business
no i'll say start find clients get testimonials
and then you niche down now the real question is
how do you actually do that how do you get started
and how do you find clients when you're new and
then how you do how do you choose a niche i i do
it the other way around people say that riches are
in the niches and i agree with that but after you
start and you have a couple of clients let me tell
you how i did it and how i teach my own students
on how to start their business so instead of and
also explain what you do by the way explain what
you do by the way oh okay so i at the moment
i coach people on how to monetize their skills
turn those skills into services or coaching or
information products so they can make money online
okay by either selling information products
to their audiences if they have an audience
or selling their services so they can you
know start an agency or start freelancing and
escape the nine to five job that they have or
um people who already have some very specific
set of skills and they want to teach other
people how to do that through coaching i
also teach people how how to turn those skills
into into coaching so they can sell it to their
online audience or outside of that okay so
when i take on a new student and they want to
start a business and they want to get clients
and they want to niche down and they want to
you know make money online and sell their services
what i do is tell them look at the moment forget
about the niche because that's a problem that
you still don't have okay you're the problem
that you have right now is getting started and
how do you get started okay you already have
the skill let's say you are you are a web designer
you can design websites okay now let's grab that
skill and let's turn it into a service you
get paid a thousand two thousand five thousand
dollars depending on your skill level okay how do
you do that we can talk about that later on but
for the moment let me tell you like the full
picture once you once you turn that skill
into a service or a coaching or product then
you set your eyes on the price getting clients
the big question now how do i get my first client
this is where most people just start thinking
about i need to find a niche i need to research
the niche i need to understand what they think
i need to understand the problems that they
have screw all of that you're starting out so
the pros dot what you need to do is reach out to
your family and your friends and tell them hey
i just started a business i started a web design
agency and i would love to design a website for
you you don't have to pay me or we could talk
about a payment so you don't feel bad about for
abusing our our relationship let's hop on a call
10 minutes and let's figure out a path to create
that website of yours so you can start promoting
yourself so you can start posting your blog so
you can start you know just using the the online
tools that i will provide you to make more money
or whatever okay you and i can assure you you'll
find a couple of your friends or family members or
acquaintances that will need that service of yours
in this case web design you don't have to charge
but if you want to charge charge at
least between 500 and a thousand dollars
because at the end of the day what you want
is the testimonial you want the social proof
why do you want the social proof of the
testimonial well when people are in doubt
we humans what we do is we take a look around
us and we figure out what are other people doing
oh they're hiring jose for web design okay i
see their face i see that they say good things
about jose let me give this jose guy a try they
hop on a call with jose jose says okay here's
what we're going to do xyrcy pay me 500 pay me a
thousand dollars pay me five thousand dollars pay
me whatever you need to ask for your services and
then you get another client but at first focus on
the people that you know your acquaintances your
friends your family members because here's the
thing you might fail that's a possibility but
you will yeah this is something that happens
you you will fail eventually okay that's just a
fact you're going to die fact you're going to fail
eventually fact so it's a little bit less
heartbreaking to fail when you're working with a
family member or or a friend because they'll give
you the chance to redeem yourself but a client
they'll fire you right there so that's why i
always suggest start with five family members
and um acquaintances are people that you trust
because then you can like in case of failure
in case which i it's doubtful if you're a
responsible person but in case of failure
you can always ask for an extra two or three
days to deliver on your promises and that's
okay it can happen it will happen eventually
so reduce the risk by working with people that
you feel comfortable telling them hey give
me a couple of extra days i will deliver your
stuff and if i don't i'll give you your money back
that's okay and i'll of course deliver the service
and it's a great way to get started and make money
and um use that money to if you want to invest
the money that's okay right buy bitcoin or buy
the what what do what do you call it safe coins
i i have no safe no no we don't promote safe
moon on layers podcasts we just promote bitcoin
oh okay okay okay but i i don't i don't know
anything about that oh you don't we can talk about
safe moon or safe coin or safe whatever i'm
like what is she talking about none of that
stuff is safe no no no um but one of the things
that i think people often um struggle with is
procrastination and motivation building habits and
things like that um so before i ask the questions
i want to give like a bit of background and
a story so i think staying motivated can be
hard and the thing which keeps me motivated
is so simple it's literally survival okay
so i look at it as like nobody is is going to pay
for me but me um like there's there's no one it's
it's i've just got me in in this world so you know
if i want to leave a country if i want to eat a
nice dinner if i want to go buy a nice bottle of
wine like seriously i want to get that perfume
only i'm no one's paying for it but me so i have
to work so and you and i really have to work not
just get like a basic job which pays me like
a a low salary that's not gonna give me um a
lifestyle that i that i want so the way i look
at it is just damn i need to survive you know
if i want to travel this world then that's what
i got to do so what's your advice to people who
struggle staying motivated and then they get they
fall down the whole procrastination rabbit hole
if you if you are a man have a kid get someone
pregnant that will give you the urgency the
urgency of god to get things done joking aside um
survival is a big one survival is like a huge one
and i like for example how jordan peterson frames
it think about the worst case scenario 10 years
from now see yourself in the worst place that you
can never see yourself and use that fear of that
eerie image that hell of an image as a way to
force yourself to get things done because if you
don't do those things that you know you should be
doing you'll end up in that hell hole and believe
me it can be worse than what your imagination can
take you if you can't find motivation on that fear
that's okay find it in the positive figure out
like where you want to be if you're more like that
i'm more in the fear-based side i prefer to scare
my [ __ ] scare myself shitless so i get things
done but not everyone respond to fear okay so what
you do is think about where you want to be in the
next 10 years you want to be in dominican republic
in punta cana surrounded by beautiful latino
and latino people with a great body shredded
having you know the breeze in the in in the in
cares in your face and the sun you know shining
shining upon you and and toasting your your skin
and you become a beautiful um
tanned person and shredded person
imagine yourself like that and then find a
way to get there and that takes me to what i
told you about a couple of moments ago when
we began the podcast figure out the problem
the immediate problem that you have right now
figure out a solution to that problem and then
find another problem that you can figure out the
solution at that same moment and do that until
the problems that you have are longer are the
have long-term consequences and then figure out
how to solve those problems that have long-term
consequences but at the moment figure out the
problems that you have that have a short-term
consequence because you're starting out okay
um so i just told you about two ways to motivate
yourself you either use fear by thinking about
where you beat in 10 years and the worst case
scenario that can happen in the next 10 years or
you can use a little bit of positivity or positive
positive thinking to imagine yourself in the place
that you want to be 10 years from now two tactics
that work really well and depending on who you
are if you're like me you can use fear if you're
like liar you can also use fear you know a fear
of you know i don't fear of not surviving okay
but if you're like not like me or like you um
use positivity and use a better mental
image of the future that you want to live in
i think that's the thing people get so wrapped up
in thinking that they've got this huge path ahead
of them and this huge gigantic journey and that
can be so overwhelming and it totally stops you
from starting um but if you just literally take it
step by step um and go with it do the small things
um i think that really helps something which i
always struggle with um particularly you know
when you're working for yourself is prices raising
prices this is so stressful um so let's go back a
bit how would you how do you work out how to value
the price of something if you're starting out
always start between 500 and a thousand dollars
don't complicate it really overthinking pricing
when you're starting out is just too much
price between 500 and a thousand dollars
that depends on the product obviously if you're
not if you're doing it here's a service okay if
it's a service or coaching 500 to 1000 no matter
the service no matter the coaching five hundred
two thousand dollars because you'll be selling
your time okay now if it's like digital products
or physical products it's a little bit different
okay um price low and as you start getting more
testimonials you raise the price that's that's a
process start with 50 raise the price when you get
more testimonials then make it 75 then 100 then
150 then 500 then a thousand then whatever you
think and you can even build a coaching around
around that information product which is what i
do you know i i let me tell you how i started with
the with the coaching business so i said to myself
how can i build a course how can i build a digital
product how could i be create this video course
knowing that it will solve people pro people's
problems and not waste my time creating it only to
fail to sell it once it's done what i did was the
following hey i just opened up five uh spots for
a coaching it's only 500 i will show you how to do
this this this and that i got five people to join
because it's only five hundred dollars it's only
five hundred dollars and i coached them on how to
whatever in that time okay that was in 2018 i
got the five people to join my coaching for 500
and i started building the information product
around the questions that they had that they asked
me and um i got paid to build the information
product and then i saw the information product
outside of the coaching so i found a way to
win even if i failed what do i mean with that
i got paid for the coaching and the purpose was
of course to coach but also to build a product
that i could sell outside of that coaching if
the product would have not sold well i still made
the money from the coaching that's what i mean
when i say find a way to win even if you fail
okay i didn't fail i made a lot
of money with the coaching and the
and the information products but at least i uh
i got paid basically to create the information
product this is the ultimate way to create
an information product man you have the the
people that will serve as a guinea pig let's say
they will ask you questions you'll answer those
questions and then you've record that and add it
to your top you documented that you add it to a
powerpoint presentation and then you record
yourself reading the powerpoint presentation
and then you sell that evergreen process works
perfectly and it also helps you make money while
creating the information product okay so i want to
talk a little bit about more about that concept of
finding ways in which you can win even if you
fail i saw this concept from scott adams he's uh
one of my favorite authors and when he said that
years ago i think it was 2016 when i started like
following him really deeply i got i got
that idea of actually figuring out how i
can win even if i fail and that's where i created
something a platform a membership platform that i
call sovereign university okay i started serving
university in 2019 um and i got a hundred members
in the first month they were paying me between
forty five dollars and forty four dollars and
fifty dollars a month a hundred members that's
around five thousand dollars in in monthly revenue
and let me tell you i failed because i closed the
university okay but i also won because i created
so much content so many courses for people inside
the sovereign university that i was able to make
ten times that tens not ten times that much
more than ten times the money i made with
some university for example from my time when i
had some university back then which i reopened
la on monday by the way um i created a course the
course is how to create websites without coding
okay it was for members of summer university back
in 2019. once i stopped like once i like oh man
some university this is too much for me and
i closed it i sold the course the straight
line web design course that course has
made me over a hundred thousand dollars
wow so i lost because i failed because i had
to close the university but i had all that
information then i that then i monetized outside
of the university so i figured out a way to win
even if i lost in your life think about those
situations where you think you might fail because
there's a it's always a possibility but even
if you fail you win for example learning skills
or skill learning any type of skill will always
produce some kind of good results even if you
fail to for example monetize that skill become
famous doing whatever you're doing with that skill
you will still have that skill let's say that
you want to learn how to write and you want to
sell the writing skill we call that copywriting
like writing for persuading that's copywriting
let's say that you fail to create a agency around
copywriting you get a couple of clients but then
you're just making ten thousand dollars a month
and you say like oh it's too much work for too
too little money what happens next you still have
the copywriting skill you can teach other people
that skill or you can use that skill for your
own gains you can launch on a newsletter you get
people to join your newsletter and then you sell
them stuff in that newsletter it could be coaching
on how to copyright it could be coaching on on how
to start a business it could be coaching it could
be information products it could be whatever the
hell you can imagine you can sell with that skill
so you found skill that even if you failed
let's say monetizing that skill you still
keep that skill and then you start stacking
more of these skills that they add up
okay they add up and they help you become more
persuasive they help you become a more valuable
individual they help you become an individual
that actually provides more value to the world
and when you provide value to the world a lot
of great things start happening to you let's say
yourself you provide a lot of free value on
your on your twitter account and that's why
you have a hundred thousand followers okay
and you say oh i sometimes post silly videos
and you do and they're funny because they
they are endearing you know like you said
and you risk embarrassment and risk embarrassment
paid off massively you now have a hundred thousand
followers liking your stuff retweeting your
stuff you now have people paying you paying
you just to name them on your podcast or i don't
know if they're paying you but they're giving
you something no yeah your sponsors they give you
something it could be fi some financial something
financially or a privilege of early access to some
stuff but they give you something in exchange for
just opening your mouth and saying this pasca this
podcast is sponsored by jose rosado and that's all
you have to do why because you risk embarrassment
and you did to put it you put in the work and i
bet when you started tweeting it was weird right
you felt a little bit of comfortable you said like
what can people learn from me what can people find
how can people find interest in what i have to say
i'm just when you started out twitter you had
like 22 years when you were like how many 22 23.
oh i've been on twitter for years but i
i i wasn't trying to grow i only started
march last year march last year and from march
last year when you started taking it seriously
what happened you grew yeah the worst case
scenario is that what your account doesn't grow
but still you get some kind of reward for posting
about bitcoins and about the things that you love
so you found a way to win even if you lose and
when i say lose it's not getting the followers
but winning looks like this you build a community
you reach out to famous people you have access to
other people on the platform you can communicate
with them you can send them a direct message i saw
you posting the other day that you want to have
elon musk on your on your podcast and i believe
you'll be able to pull that one out how i have
no freaking idea but that eventually will happen
yeah you put it out there in the world the worst
thing that can happen is that elon musk doesn't
come to your podcast and meh you know like okay
i'll have jose rosa or i have whatever i have
someone else okay so um you put yourself in the
in a place of of risking embarrassment by saying
i want to have ilan on my podcast elon come and
you tweet that and you tweeted that it might work
it might not work so you found a way to win
even if you lose you win because you had the
uh the balls let's say the ovaries to say
yes you could say [ __ ] chill yeah yeah yeah
a a you had the guts to say elon i want to i want
to um interview you i want to have you as a guest
on my podcast he doesn't come nothing happens he
comes and you win you win you get more famous liar
goes from 100 000 followers to 500 000 followers
from day to night from tonight today i don't know
i don't know how to say it yeah but um that's what
happens when you put yourself out there and you
stick your neck out risking that someone grasped a
machete and you know cut your head it's true it's
like they say um it's okay you breathe you breathe
i'll take it from i'll take it i'll take this bit
it's it's like they say you know if you don't ask
you don't get basically um and yeah no i mean i'm
i'm happy to embarrass myself to be honest because
at least i at least i have fun and at least i
i make myself laugh that's all that matters um
but you know we're talking about building online
businesses as if it's so obvious that one should
do it right um and i to some people it's not to me
it is just given everything we've seen with covert
and everything like that but in your words why
would you say it's so important to build an online
business or just to be able to make money online
speed speed okay speed because what's the
difference between an online business and
enough and offline business speed the process is
the same offline or online you need clients you
need to find clients no matter if it's offline
or online no matter if it's online or offline
you need to find clients and with the
internet it's so much faster to get started
because let me tell you let's
say that you want lya's your
um you want to create her website let's say
all you have to do is open your twitter account
record yourself saying the following words
hey liam i love how you how enthusiastic you
are with your tweets and with your videos and i
noticed that you know you could actually start
let's say um leveraging that attention that you
get on twitter and i notice that you don't have
a website i would love to create a website for
you if this sounds like something that you want
for your business reply to this message and i
would love i would love to have a quick 10 minute
chat with you that's all you have i have to say i
actually had somebody do that um a few months ago
exactly like that and i'm gonna guess from that
message he's um a client maybe a follower no
client that's right i'm gonna guess maybe maybe
who knows but that's it that's all you have to do
it's so much faster that going to a door knocking
it and saying hey my name is jose can i talk to
the manager no you have because you have the
secretary or some or or somebody that would say
no no no no go away he's busy or she's busy online
you find the owner on twitter you find the owner
on instagram you find the owner on linkedin
which is a great platform to find the owners
and you send them a direct message directly
to them offering your services okay and it's
less risky than and less frightening
than calling someone out of the blue
we call this called calling it's really hard to
call someone like hey i have this for you do you
want to buy it i hate that i it you know i'm not
someone that gets embarrassed quickly or that has
that kind of personality that says like oh it's
scary to do that but called calling someone to
me that's scariest really oh i don't do it it
scares me i i don't i don't want to be rejected
with you know hearing it i don't but i prefer to
be rejected with a with a word with just someone
typing the word no it feels less personal so
um there's a great thing about the online world
speed i want to just jump in um because another
thing which i really want to just talk about for
a sec actually which i had no plans for talking
about but let's just do it anyway is email okay
newsletters aside reaching out to somebody
via email is dead right no see i totally need
newsletters yes but emails as if like if i want
to get you on my podcast i dm you i don't i don't
email you if i want to do business with you i
dm you i don't email you there's certain truth
truth behind that you know um it takes balls
to dm the owner of tesla you know no i do think
so yes yes the thing is that you are courageous
you are a courageous woman okay but most people
are sk you don't think it but that's what we see
and that's what i see in you you are a courageous
woman you take risks you show your face you stick
your neck out and you risk people telling you
stop talking what the hell are you talking
about someone said i'll just say someone
said on tick tock actually yesterday oh no
it's that bell end again and i was just like
oh and that's like you know you i can only imagine
the the type of dms that people send you from you
know dick pics and stuff like that from shut your
mouth and the b word you know you risk that kind
of messages you know so you are a courageous woman
you are a courageous individual and people see
that and that's one of the main reasons also when
you have a hundred thousand followers because you
are risking embarrassment and a lot of people
don't have the the courage to do that okay so
believe it believe it you are courageous
person so um back to the topic email is that um
dm is the king okay but emails if you automate it
is the universe it's more than just that it's the
creator because you can automate that okay you
can automate to reach out reaching out to people
let's say that you have 20 emails of people that
you want to invite to your podcast very important
people you can automate that you can totally
automate that you put the emails in the database
and you can send those 20 emails custom tailored
for that person where you just in the first line
you talk a little bit about them but then
everything else the invitation and the links
it's like copy paste so all you have to do is the
first line of that email to get their attention
um you personalize it you custom tailor for their
for for who they are so they know that you did
your [ __ ] research sorry oh i hate when people
do that yeah of course you can but i would just
say when people do that okay the thing i i forgot
to ask you if i can curse so so they [ __ ] know
that you conducted your research and that you
know who you are reaching to okay and then it's
just copy paste the the the rest of the thing and
you can automate that crap so instead of spending
10 hours dming people one by one you put that
those 20 30 100 emails in the database you create
a custom meme first line for these people to get
their attention everything else is copy paste
and here's the thing the follow-up can also
be automated the follow-up is the hardest
part because it's the one that you'll have to be
like hey bumping this up hey i'm gonna know what
you're doing you can't just milk it yeah so you
have to follow up follow up follow up follow up
in your case how many times do you have to
follow up on our on someone that you want to
interview i guess that's something you have to
follow up five i don't do emails i just don't um
just on that point though most my photos are in
crypto so they'll know a guy called bruce fenton
i've been trying to get bruce on i'm i finally
interviewed him but i've been trying to act
you're being courageous right now you're making
that into reality you want to interview him and
you're saying it right now that takes courage no
like we what i'm saying is like i did interview
him but i'd been messaging only only like last
month but i've been messaging him since like 2018.
so it took me three years and um i was like bruce
it's me again you know i just want to have a chat
um so yeah it's funny but you can automate that
with emails so you don't have to be like yeah so
that's the thing if you're doing it manually email
it's really uh it's just a lot of time low return
on investment but if you automate it and there are
a lot of um software to do that you can give an
there's something also called i believe g-mass
d-m-a-s-s let me see g-mass where you can like
just add a couple of emails custom add some like
tags and stuff like that to change the first name
of the person and stuff like that and you can send
a bunch of emails custom tailored for the person
that integrates gmask integrates perfectly with
gmail so it's it's really really really powerful
you said g mass g-m-a-s-s perfect mass
massive okay yeah good so um you automate that
and you don't have to be spending
time on hey i'm here it's me again
so that's one of the great things about
emails you can automate it but the dm
it's more personal and also i appreciate them
yeah people appreciate the at least the effort of
reaching out you know like it's very personal
because it's a direct message to the person
and they see that they see the courage of you just
saying hey it's me again and if you send a video
it's even more courageous which i highly encourage
people to send video messages instead of just
text message because it takes a lot of courage
to record yourself hey lia i want to create
your website if you're interested say yes
and we can have a quick chat on on how to
make that happen so if you're anyone who is
listening right now here's what i want you to do
once we stop this recording if you have a service
and you feel that layer or me or some i hope you i
hope i pronounce your name right i always call you
liar it's okay it's okay it's it's actually leia
it's more of an a sound but i mean you're
english literally yeah i'm not gonna yeah
no no you i'm like damn i i've been thinking am i
pronouncing this this name correctly i'm you know
i just ripped and i i risk embarrassment
and now i just embarrassed myself so um
back to the main topic go into people's dms record
yourself um telling them that you want to create
something for them it could be content it could
be a website it could be emails it could be
let's say the person needs a lawyer and you're a
lawyer send them a video oh oh yeah look look leia
needs a lawyer so if you're a lawyer and you're
listening to this podcast she needs a liar slide
into her the abs and send her a pitch i want to
be your lawyer so it's not simple well it's not
easy but it's simple the process is simple you let
people know what you do and if they have a problem
that you can solve they'll say okay let's have
a quick chat and once you have them on the phone
you do your magic you tell them about the benefits
of working with you you offer them a guarantee and
you close the deal on the phone of course i'm
simplifying the process but regardless if it's
online business or offline business it works the
same because at the end of the day at the end of
the day what you want to build is connection with
people you want to build that um sense of trust
with the person and you can do that online and
offline so again the difference between offline
and online business is speed online is just much
more faster than offline and of course it depends
on the business because there are some offline
businesses that make a lot of money um but um if
you're more in the service based type of business
online is just faster because you have the emails
you have the direct messages you can automate all
of that you can automate all of that and you can
just let the machine the computer do the grunt
work for you and you focus on closing the deal
on the phone because at the end of the day you
will have to have a quick chat with that person
either on zoom or the phone or just a phone call
usually soon because we now have been forced to
you know to have some calls which i love i love it
i don't have to to go to other people's businesses
to have a meeting i can just send them a assume
link and that's it that's online business man
really if you're thinking about online business
like selling information products it's a little
bit different but if you are a service based
business meaning a do it for you business i
will do that for you use the online resources and
tools that you have at your disposal emails direct
messages social media linkedin is a special one
to make money twitter to talk about what you do
twitter is especially good to sell services it's
insanely powerful and people just think it's for
politics or or for i don't know bitcoin or
whatever it's such well you can make a lot
of money with bitcoin but a it's so much more than
politics bitcoin and [ __ ] posting so much more
than that elon for example i remember he posted
with a tweet he just posted about the tesla short
pants i remember they sold out like in a minute
from a tweet and of course he's elon you know
he's he has that star power but he used his online
following um to he leveraged his online following
to drive traffic to that uh to that landing page
to sell his his short paths so if you're not using
the online tools you're missing out on speed
on making things work out faster for you
i think the most um one of i mean there's a
lot of important stuff there but what's really
important i think what really resonates with
me um is the idea of personalizing a message
and not [ __ ] that up um so something which
i think actually jose you and i actually spoke
about this a few months ago um you sent me a
dm and you were like um women posting their l's
um but i think i think you missed the point so
basically well i get i get messages sometimes
and the messages are um we need more women in
crypto love what you're doing blah blah blah
let's work together and i get frustrated when
i receive messages like that because i'm really
vocal about being um sort of against that kind of
identity politics um i'm not really interested in
we need more anything in anything and i'm really
vocal about it so when i get people reaching out
to me saying yeah leia we need more women in
and i'm like that's an outright like disrespect
because you're because you're you're
pretending that you follow me but you don't
like you just you've literally just told me that
you're lying because i think anybody that follows
me knows that i'm i i talk about us all the time
and to me it's just an outright like i don't
follow you but i'm gonna lie and pretend that i do
or i i don't know who you're like i don't know who
you are but i'm gonna pretend i do know who you
are basically and that yeah you could you can be
honest you can just say you can just say like i've
literally just found you um and um i i really like
what i've seen so far blah blah like at least just
be honest about it i hate it it's just it's the
lying which which just like really frustrates me
um so anyway you're really knowledgeable about all
of this um but how did you become so knowledgeable
about it where did all of this start because every
time i speak to you honestly i get very stressed
out i always feel there's more i need to do
um eventually i'm gonna do a newsletter
but that's towards the end of the year
no i'm like oh god i stress you out i'm
failing so let me let me redeem myself
let me redeem myself and let me find a
way to unstress you what is the question
leia no it's no question it's it's
just a chitchat isn't it it's just like
how do you not get overwhelmed you know oh that's
no no actually that isn't even the question that's
not the question the question is how did you
become so successful at knowing about all of this
like how did you become so well read on
online business that's actually the question
feeling overwhelmed it's normal at the moment
i'm overwhelmed with my i relaunched sovereign
university and i can tell you i feel lost i feel
i'm scared shitless because i failed once with
sovereign university and i relaunched it back in i
relaunched it actually it was on friday for a very
specific for very specific people and i really and
then i relaunched it for everyone on on monday and
i trust me it scares the sh [ __ ] out of me and
i'm lost and i'm like struggling to make it work
better yesterday i had a group session and there
were like 20 30 people in in the in the zoom call
and there was a q a session and i was struggling
like hell because i i found myself in front of
30 people asking me questions and
i knew that the questions were so
different because of the different levels of
skill and the business that they have that
i was answering people that had questions for
you know more advanced users let's call it
like that and i watched having newbies asking me
newbie questions and i felt like the pressure of
holy [ __ ] i got myself into this mess now
how the hell can i get outside of this mess
so since yesterday i'm thinking like how
can i provide value to people who are making
more money let's say ten thousand dollars a
month and also provide value to people who
are making a little bit less than that and now
i'm trying to find an answer to that i'm lost
but i won't let that screw my chances of winning
you know um it's normal to feel overwhelmed and
i'm stupid and dumb because i will take a two week
vacation on saturday and i launched on monday but
i said to myself it i don't launch this university
i call it southern university on monday i will not
launch this never i was supposed to launch that
uh i was supposed to launch it in january of 2021.
six months later i launched it okay so as you can
see i struggle a lot i fail a lot i doubt myself
from time to time not always but from time to time
i doubt myself and right now i can tell you i'm
lost because it's not the same thing as one-on-one
coaching this is a membership platform and i'm
new at it and despite being new the feedback has
been overwhelmingly positive at the moment i don't
think i've received a negative one but once i get
it i'll feel sad like it will crush me i'll go
to a corner and cry myself to sleep nah i'm
just joking but it will make me feel sad but
but i will find a way to take that feedback the
negative feedback and turn it into a positive how
by offering by finding the solution okay so even
though i am perceived as an expert on the things
that i do when i start something new it is really
overwhelming and hard and i'm the type of person
that um when is anxious and stress gets tight
here on the on on this muscle right i've been
tied like my those muscles have been tied for the
last six months because i i was i'm still lost in
regards to what to do next with survey university
i do have my my plans i just haven't figured out
the step by step on how to go from this
side to this side but once i figure it out
believe me i will sell something on how to
create a membership platform and be rich with
our membership platform so this is why i tell you
that if you find ways to win even if you fail you
still won so if for whatever reason i fail again
with sovereign university which i doubt this time
because i'm much more experienced than when i
started a when i started and closed it on 2018
i will still have the connection i i'm
building inside the platform i will still have
the testimonials for the courses that i
have inside the platform i will still have
um all of those resources that i'm creating
for these wonderful people that decided
to trust me and even though i'm lost i'm
overwhelmed i'm stressed i don't know what to do
they trusted me with their money they trusted me
with um asking me their questions and believing
that i will provide them the right answer and i
will win i will win and i'll repeat that again i
will win and it's normal to feel overwhelmed
with a new business or with a new endeavor
it's 100 normal because you are new
at that there's this guy david peril
i follow him on twitter hopefully he'll
follow me back one day david peril he
calls himself the right i believe the writing guy
um teaches people how to write online okay and
he talks about imposter syndrome yeah he's also
himself the writing guy dairy peril with double
l at the end um david underscore perel or peril i
don't know how to pronounce it my english is bad
so um he talks about imposter syndrome and he he
he posted a short video on imposter syndrome that
caught my attention and i internalized what
he said he said when you are starting out you
are an imposter because you are not a business
owner you are not the bitcoin expert you are not
the ultimate authority in whatever
you are starting out at the moment
but you still did and in some way
or another you are an imposter
because you you know you don't have the experience
of running a business but you cannot let that
imposter syndrome take a hold on you you need
to find the answers to the questions that are
bugging you at the moment so you can overcome that
imposter syndrome um do you ever have that yet or
still of course all the time still have that right
of course i still have that of course i still well
of course not it's not obvious you know but i do
have that you the second reason why i launched
sovereign university on monday was because my wife
told me stop being a well she didn't tell her she
didn't say she didn't say it like that like stop
being a [ __ ] i was but she literally told me
like dude she's also part of the platform she said
jose what you have inside sovereign university
i know i'm your wife and i love you but you
know that i will always tell you the truth
i'm part of other membership platforms and
being part of your platform has shown me
how much more advanced you are than the other
guys that i'm working with so and i felt like
what do you mean with that okay she told me first
the way you explain things it's easy and she's
she's english is her her second language but my
skill level is like 10 times hers so she still
needs to work more on her english and despite
that she's able to understand the the process okay
first it's more organized secondly it's easy
to understand and third i don't feel lost
following through your step-by-step instructions
when i go to the other platforms that i'm i'm
in i see a bunch of videos and a bunch of
stuff but i don't know what is the next step
and she told me like just launch the [ __ ] thing
just launch it it's i always say this almost on
every podcast that i'm invited find someone that
trusts more in your in you than what you trust
in yourself because that person is the one that
will like push you in a good way to become better
and that person to me is my wife and of course i
trust her more than she trusts yourself herself
so it's like a you give me something and i also
give you something back um my wife is actually
the reason why i started my online business for i
don't know a little over 10 years she was always
telling me jose start your online business start
your online business and in my head i was no i'm
just a [ __ ] i'm not a little [ __ ] i'm not good
at this uh [ __ ] it and she was always bugging
the hell out of me start start start start do it
do it do it do it you have it in you and she is
the top reason why i started the online business
and the reason why i relaunched sorry university
i found someone that trusted more in me than what
i trust in myself and that's a big thing because
i do trust myself a lot but i still struggle
with imposter syndrome yeah but as david peril
said when we start out every single one of us
is an imposter because we're not the person
who knows how to run a business when you're
starting out of course you will eventually become
that person but then you become the imposter
on the next level the next level the million
dollar or the 10 million dollars or the hundred
million dollars okay i still have not reached the
1 million one million dollars in
one year but i want to reach that
so currently my posture syndrome is telling me
you're not a seven figure a year person so what
the hell are you doing teaching people how to make
six figures and i said to myself well i'm a multi
here's how i lie to myself well i'm a multi-six
figure business owner so i can teach people how
to make five figures or their first six figures
yeah so that's not a lie yeah yeah well it makes
it's how i lie to myself okay i get it to to go
to push myself forward yeah um and there's no
problem with doing that it's like the fake until
you make it um i believe that just don't use it to
to scam people you need to you need to do things
really good okay or at least try your best
so um you overcome the feeling of
overwhelm by putting in the work
i'm overwhelmed right right now i'm [ __ ]
overwhelmed but regardless of that um i have this
little thingy here in my arm you see it this
is what we call a whoop app the whoop w-h-o-o-p
whoop tracks your sleep tracks
everything okay despite of that
you will not be able to see it but everything
is green it's green it means that i'm sleeping
well and that i'm doing well in regards to how i
feel and i can feel it every time this thing is
in green i really know it's it's green because i
feel good i feel it even before knowing it's green
when it's red i also feel it even before watching
the app so it's not the app that's making me feel
bad or good so despite of the overwhelm despite
of the of the sensation of being a little bit lost
i sleep well why because i know i'm doing my
best to provide value to people who trust me uh
with their money if you don't do your best you
will not be able to sleep well at night unless
you're one of those psychopaths that just want the
money but if you are a person that prides pride
him or herself in being an honest
honest risk and responsible person
you need to do your best maybe your best is
someone else's worst but that's okay with time
your best will be the best of the best test um
and that's my my philosophy at the moment i'm
struggling yes but one year from now when i have
a thousand or two thousand members in the platform
i'll have a different challenge
but i won't feel the same
stress anxiety and impostor syndrome that i'm
feeling at the moment overcome it push forward
and eventually you'll find a path to win that's
that's what i think about that long rant right
yeah you're a talker but it's good
you're you've got a lot of conviction
and um despite being overwhelmed you know exactly
what you're doing you've got you've got a path and
i think that's really important and you know
you spoke about the the university and having
that deadline and if you don't have deadlines
this is something i learned from you actually
um because i'm in the middle of creating something
at the moment and i didn't give myself a deadline
and it wasn't getting finished and now i've given
myself a deadline and i've actually been able to
um it's basically done now so um no i think i
think everything you do is absolutely brilliant um
i really love the philosophy the imposter syndrome
um what that david perrault guy said that's really
interesting as well you'll have to send me because
i couldn't find i couldn't find it on my phone
you have to send me links i'll send it to you
on twitter yeah um that's really interesting
because you you actually said something to me on
on twitter the other day you're like well that's
why you've got over 100 000 followers and i was
like yeah my head needs to catch up with that
you know i'm like i don't know why you're still
tweeting us you would ask is you had a thousand
followers i'm tweeting as if i have like 1
000 followers eventually that will get you
into trouble trust me i know because when
you find one of these accounts that will
start talking [ __ ] about you and you reply to
them and you reply to them in a very emotional way
um it's not a big deal when you have a thousand
followers but if you have a hundred thousand
followers it's different because you're punching
down and people don't like when you punch down
or at least they a lot of people don't like
that other people find it funny i find it funny
because i don't give a [ __ ] puzzle a lot
of people do give a [ __ ] so it's something
i've noticed from a lot of guys and girls that
they grow their online business their online
brand online once they reach to a certain level
they forget that so many people are watching them
and reading their stuff that they still act
as if they had a thousand followers and they
punch down and they talk [ __ ] about the other
smaller accounts so no i don't do that anyway to
be honest i think the only thing that i have to
be careful of is i get a lot of stupid responses
um so stupid i get stupid responses and i just
oh you can do the valley the valley accent oh
i can totally do an american accent like i
can totally do that like we could totally
we could have absolutely done this podcast in an
american accent that would have been awesome um i
can totally do it anyway that was anyway i can't
do it i have a good american accent oh really
you just gotta talk everything everything is up
talk so everything's gonna go like this and you
gotta ask a question after everything that you do
do um no it's not that good girl accent it's funny
it used to be better um but jose no it's been
brilliant i want to thank you so much um it's
been so interesting i always love hearing what you
have to say um and you know i find your twitter so
valuable so guys please follow jose his twitter is
absolutely brilliant i'm one of those people that
genuinely screenshots tweets that i need to
remember and jose is one of those accounts
um like i said he he tweeted something like um
if you don't set a deadline you won't get it done
and then i'm like oh my god i need to set a
deadline god so value right there so thank
you so much you don't have to say what but when
is the deadline speak it out make it a reality
so it's it's july um end of july um 2021 2021
i just need to work out one thing i don't know
i need to work out one day it has to be one
day what is the day put the deadline right now
i'm challenging you it's a challenge what's the
deadline say out to the world risk it okay the
the first month the last monday of july would
you say that the last monday of july i'm not sure
monday of july let's put a day that's the 26th of
july god i better write that down oh that's very
stressful now you have to deliver i was going to
tell you that if you want to get [ __ ] done yeah
if you have 100 000 followers tell your followers
i will launch something big on a given date
that's how you add fire under your ass
so you actually find the urgency to get
it done and now you've done that you've got
yourself into a pickle and you will deliver
you will deliver because you'll have
a deadline the 26th of july of 2021
miss leia will launch something i don't know what
but she will stress me out jose that's what i mean
okay all right i'll deal with it i know what
i need to do and i also need like um other
people that i'm that i'm working with to launch
this to hurry up so all right we'll get it done
um jose thank you so much guys thank you so
much for um listening we've had some really
interesting comments so i'd recommend checking out
the youtube jose afterwards just to have a look
but yeah people really enjoyed it there's moon
rocket ape who said this was pretty solid honestly
so thanks moon rocket ape um and jose manuel
has also commented um so yeah no it's been
really great um so also where can people
find you just before we end the podcast
they can find me at jose rosal on on twitter
and on youtube too i believe um on there's no
ads on youtube so just write jose rosale i'll
be the first one to appear on instagram it's
jose rosado r-o-s-a-d-o h-q as high quality
okay um and uh my website rosa.orosa
dot d o which is my last name okay rosado rosa dot
d o um that's all that's how you can find me or
when leia retweets something hit the follow button
once you see me on her timeline there you go thank
you so much everyone we'll be back next week and
jose of course thank you again bye bye always bye